maintenant avec brecht qui revient à
sérieusement à la mode sandrine bonnaire
le jour dans le nord de paris marcel
maréchal s'apprête à le monter à
marseille et à la comédie française
antoine vitez montrent la vie de galilée
de brecht donc dans des décors de yannis
kokkos surprise tout est déjà loué alors
pourquoi cet engouement pour brecht
tentative d'explication de didier
epelbaum et pascal pons à travers cette
vie de galilée au français je vous
rappelle que galilée et l'homme qui
s'est battu pour la vérité contre la foi
et l'église il affirmait que c'était la
terre qui tournait autour du soleil et
non pas l'inversé
voici le monde de brecht vu par antoine
vitez en quelques traits de pinceaux de
yannis kokkos qui traduisent une
complicité de 20 ans et plus comment
faire
la transmission de pensée la tradition
de pensée après ça il nous plonge dans
le xviie siècle mais le langage de
galilée nous est étrangement familier
non malheureux le pays qui a besoin de
héros l'actualité de brecht le poète qui
s'est identifiée au communisme dans les
années 50 c'est qu'il a entrevu
l'effondrement du système nous apporte
un état de la réflexion antérieure à cet
effondrement est d'une certaine manière
quand on les écoute quand on écoute bien
on s'aperçoit qu'il ya comme une
prémonition de cet effondrement alors
vraiment je crois qu'il ya des raisons
qu'on s'y intéresse
nous avons yannis kokkos et moi
entraîner le spectateur depuis le début
du xviie siècle jusqu'à la fin du xxème
et ça se passe d'une façon un peu
insensible et puis petit à petit ça
s'accentue
certains personnages restent dans le
xviie siècle italien et d'autres au
contraire sont carrément dans la fin de
notre sinistre et cruelle xxème siècle
il est imperméable gris sont ceux de
toutes les polices politiques galilée on
devrait dire aujourd'hui que c'était un
dissident non celui qui connaissant la
vérité d'un homme mensonge celui là est
un criminel c'est j'en doute de tout on
nous fonder la société humaine sur le
dos des nombreux sur la voie bien que
confronté à un pape du xviie siècle ce
galilée le public de la comédie
française le reconnaît comme un
contemporain
[Musique]